meanwhile mark leibovich is the chief
national correspondent for the New York
Times Magazine and a CBS News political
contributor good enough to join us now
from Washington and Mark good morning to
you we now know 13 different devices
perhaps used by Hillary Clinton the
Secretary of State none recovered some
perhaps destroyed by a hammer a laptop
with archived information gone missing a
candidate who says she may have been
confused early and often about the whole
thing optically how bad is this for the
campaign well I think the whole thing is
a big optical problem I mean it's a
muddle I mean muddle seems to be the
word of the day I think people have not
really bought her explanations you know
from the very beginning here but I think
unless you have video of Hillary Clinton
taking a sledgehammer to her 13 devices
it's probably not that big of a deal but
it still does add to the level of
distrust that has dogged her from the
very beginning so I think in so much as
these stories just keep coming they're
going to be a problem for her mark you
mentioned the distrust and that's what
we're seeing in some new polling even
out that a majority think that it's
becoming harder to believe her
explanations that she's running for
office for her own good not to actually
help the American people it's sort of
twofold can she get elected with numbers
like that and what does it mean for her
if she does well i canna cancer can
certainly get elected with numbers like
that largely because her opponents
numbers are worse I mean it certainly
whoever wins in November November is
going to face a very challenging
landscape not only politically but
because they're going to come in very
very damaged because if you see these
numbers now I don't think it would
improve much between now and November so
obviously this has been a tough campaign
I think the next couple of months going
to be just as tough if not worse and
it's going to be a very very you know
sort of dicey thing to watch but look I
mean neither of them I think are going
to be surprised by this but we're going
to see how it goes from here mark let's
talk about Donald Trump's visit to a
black church in Detroit over the weekend
he said then we need a civil rights
agenda for our time is he really making
a pitch for black Americans and other
minorities where he's got historically
bad numbers or is there another strategy
here well I think the fact that he's
there is significant and I think that he
will get credit
or actually just showing up in the black
community in a black church which is not
something that you saw do you
traditionally see Republican nominees
for president doing at this stage of the
game so that itself I think could be
very at the very least in olive branch
to to the african-american community
especially at a time where you know the
enthusiasm that that community has for
Hillary Clinton at this point is very
much you know it's it's it's an open
question I mean we have a story today in
the New York Times about you know that
there is some lack of enthusiasm for
Hillary Clinton certainly compared to
the first african-american president
barack obama so i think at the very
least it's an opening for him that he is
seizing you say that he will get credit
for it but did he accomplish anything in
that and going to that church probably
not significantly I mean I think
obviously this is not going to be you
know a big part of his winning coalition
if he were to prevail in November but
again I mean if you're going to think
purely in terms of optics and showing up
you know this is something for for him
to you know at least point to and say
that that I'm trying to reach out to new
constituencies he says he's going to
keep going back so I mean we'll see but
I think for now it certainly don't I
don't think will hurt him in any way
mark leave it Mitch thanks as always
okay